hi it's Matthew Martin from details and
we just finished the Louis Vuitton Show
and I am obsessed with it it was ultra
luxe and super elegant the camel coats
in the beginning were really beautiful
there were a lot of them were belted
there were these fantastic blanket
scarves and blanket coats there was
super huge which was a really bold
statement there was a mix of suits
cheese has stood out my mind the most
were this blue Tweedy looking
double-breasted suit there's absolutely
beautiful and they also had a grayish
version that was single breasted and
those are really nice
they have these really cool accessories
that were these pins with feathers on
them that they had on the lapels of the
jackets and I thought that looks really
modern and really sleek there were these
really gorgeous camel colored bags
almost like a caramely color and I
hadn't seen that yet from them and I
really enjoyed it a bunch of berets they
were nice they didn't look too affected
as sometimes a break-in look and they
were more military kid style and they
were super elegant most of the shoes and
the boots in the show have these really
cool metal tips on the toe and in the
heel that was a really modern way for a
shoe to look follow me on twitter at
details madam for more videos from Paris
go to details com